- [Narrator] It seems like every year,
there's a real threat of a...
- [Reporter 1] Government shutdown
- [Reporter 2] Lawmakers
racing to reach a deal
to avoid a government shutdown.
- [Narrator] And 2023 is no different.
- Saturday, 11:59 PM, deadline to avoid
a government shutdown.
- [Narrator] Here's why the government
is constantly on the verge of a shutdown.
For starters, the US is the only country
that even can shut down.
Everywhere else, if a government agency
doesn't have a budget
for the new fiscal year,
they just use last
year's and keep working.
But because 150 years ago,
a bunch of US agencies would blow
through their entire budget
or appropriations in a few months,
Congress passed the Anti-Deficiency Act,
saying it wasn't lawful to spend any sum
in excess of appropriations
made by Congress
for that fiscal year.
Basically, if Congress doesn't pass
a new funding bill every year,
agencies can't spend a dime and shut down.
But why that keeps threatening to happen
a century later comes down to Congress?
For one, these spending bills
are kind of their big thing.
- The one thing that Congress
has to do with the president
is write the bills to keep the
government open and working.
There are a lot of measures
that should be done or could be done,
but this is the be-all,
end-all of must pass.
- [Narrator] So these
spending bills end up becoming
a vessel for all kinds of
other things like last year's.
Sure, it funded things
like the Department of
Agriculture and Energy
and the Department of Defense,
but it also created the Alaska
Salmon Research Task Force,
renamed a bunch of post offices,
and changed policy on
the protection of whales
in the North Atlantic,
which environmental activists
were adamantly opposed to.
- Other things are gonna catch a ride,
and that's sort of the
reality of living in a world
where Congress struggles to legislate.
- [Narrator] She isn't exaggerating.
This is the number of laws
that each session of Congress has enacted.
Not only is Congress trending
towards fewer and fewer laws,
but so far this session, they're
off to a really slow start,
they're on pace to not
even create a hundred.
- If there's so few things
that make it to the floor,
it's the target, it's your
opportunity to make a stand.
It makes it harder and harder
to reach those agreements
in the first place.
- [Narrator] In theory,
they should be reaching
those agreements with something called
a budget resolution by about mid-April,
but that hasn't happened in 20 years.
Then they're supposed to
pass those spending bills
by the new fiscal year
deadline, October 1st.
Here's how many spending bills
have been passed by then.
It's been 26 years since all
of them were done on time.
They usually pass a short-term
stopgap funding bill
or a continuing resolution
to fund the government
for just a little bit.
- And that's why it's seemingly
that we come back in
December quite frequently,
and that's when the rubber hits the road
for actually compiling
all these final decisions
on spending bills.
- [Narrator] The ideological
divide in Congress is growing.
Republicans are more conservative,
Democrats are more liberal,
and then there's few members
who meet somewhere in the middle.
- Polarization exacerbates
difficulties in the process here.
- [Narrator] You can see
it in split districts too
where voters elected a
representative from one party
and voted the opposite
party for president.
Today, Congress is one
of the fewest numbers
of split districts in the last 100 years.
- It reinforces partisanship,
it makes it harder to
reach final agreements
where you have to reach
across the party line,
and it creates an incentive for speakers
like McCarthy never to wanna
deal with the Democrats,
but to deliver on behalf
of his party's conference,
not on behalf of what the Democrats want.
(suspenseful music)
- [Narrator] So a
disorganized budget process,
plus a lack of opportunity
to debate things,
plus a lack of motivation to
compromise on those things,
means funding the government
is unsurprisingly a battle.
- Look, I'm working everything we can
to make sure this doesn't happen.
(suspenseful music)